foreign
hello there George camel here co-host of
the Ramsey Show and I'm back again with
another episode of the best of the
Ramsay show if you've been paying
attention to the housing market lately
you know that the struggle is real it's
just wondering what to do about it and
the right time to do it this episode is
for you check out these calls all about
real estate
Brian is with us in Kansas City hey
Brian welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thank you
um so my question today is uh basically
me and my wife decided that this was
going to be the best year to build a
house and we're kind of finding out
that's not really true
so we went under contract two months ago
um gave our contractor the earnest money
and the deposit
haven't really heard a lot back from our
contractor
um they haven't Broken Ground yet and
then last week we got an email that said
due to material prices increase that
they have to raise the price of us
um of the materials and they have to
raise the price of the house
so
um basically I kind of pushed back on
that one back and forth with them for a
little bit and they said in the contract
that there's paragraph 30 they have the
right to raise the price based on
material
um so to look to my mortgage guy
and he had his legal team look at it and
it looks like the only out that we have
is if the loan gets denied they
illegally has to give us our money back
um what do you think about the morality
of that does that seem like a moral
choice that's good does it not
um just your thoughts that you that you
walk away from the deal
yes sir okay uh not the morality of them
raising prices
no not the morality
yeah that was dumb
uh so what is the how much did they
raise the uh prices
uh 3.5 percent says about ten thousand
dollars
uh and the other thing in the email they
said is that they can no longer lock
down prices with their vendors so
whenever the order
say lumber for frame of the house
whatever the price of lumber is that day
is what we'll have to pay so it looks
like the price of the house is going to
increase also
more than what they've already told you
yes sir okay and what's the price range
of the home what is the price overall
uh the price was 313 and it's about 325
now
and what's your household income
about 90 000. okay
well
um to start with let's just say that
what they're telling you is the truth
Lumber is going up rapidly
that's not a lie
um and uh and they have the contractual
ability to raise the price and my guess
is the Market's hot enough that if you
don't buy the house they can sell
somebody else
I would agree yeah so I I don't think
they're going to be harmed in this
situation
um
but basically you'd have to get a turn
down letter uh turning you down for the
loan from your mortgage broker
yeah he said that's no problem okay
all right
um
I don't have an issue with the morality
I mean the deal has changed uh nobody in
this deal anticipated that the deal was
going to change uh and based on the
change you don't want to be in the deal
you know I don't want to be in a house
but I feel like
I kind of got you know
the the bad end of the stick I don't I
don't think you're getting the bad end
of the stick I think I think if you're
if you were building a Cost Plus house
which is how I build mine meaning I buy
I pay the cost and I pay the Builder a
flat fee to manage the project you would
be absorbing all of the increases
I'm building a commercial building that
we break ground on a conference center
here and our steel prices doubled and we
hadn't even broke ground yet and I'm
that's all on me because the contractor
just manages the project in a commercial
project they don't they don't it's not
it's not a turnkey deal they pay they
pay them a contractor fee and we pay the
materials and so
um and still doubled
and uh so I've just got to go well I
don't really want to do this well yeah
I'm going to do it but I told him going
by the steel and put it out there in the
field somewhere so it doesn't double
again in the next 18 months while we're
screwing around with this thing but
um but that that's the reality steel
plywood uh Lumber packages uh glue uh
wire uh there's a shortage of everything
because all the factories shut down
during covet and the shortage has driven
the price up uh and then add to that
that the real estate market got white
hot coming out of covet in most areas so
I don't I don't think you're being who
dude I don't think they're messing you
over if I did I just pull a plug on a
heartbeat just on principle but
uh the other thing is this
um you know at 10 years from today
uh is this all you're still going to be
thinking about if you're living in this
house
I feel like probably yeah yeah it's
going to eat at you for yeah you need to
get out of a deal then
because it's just going to eat at you
okay but I don't think this guy's I
don't think this guy's a crook
okay yeah you know how do you get that
vibe from him either it's just they're
asking us to take their word like hey
you know we're telling you we don't know
what the prices are going to be but
please take our word that we're going to
try not to raise the prices and yeah
he's not trying though that didn't work
last time yeah but I mean but but the
differences on Med expectations you guys
entered into this nobody saw this Lumber
shortage coming and so I mean he's
probably built houses 10 years and never
faced this one time
and all of a sudden the stinking Lumber
package went up you know a ton and
that's a major component in a
residential home is a lumber package
it's your biggest item on your line
items and so you know he's
he he's like crap no I got to go do now
I got to go deal with a customer who's
gonna be mad like I did something wrong
and I didn't do anything wrong I just
got screwed myself by the situation so
um I I don't think the guy's a bad guy
um he is passing the cost on to you
which he contractually nobody ever
thought you'd ever activate that little
own Clause of the contract but he's able
to do that and uh so but I think the
biggest thing is you're just not ever
going to be happy here
so you're better off to be done
the Suzanne out in Spokane hey what's up
Suzanne
hey there hi there how's it going
love that it Rhymes Suzanne in Spokane
it just made me happy it's good to have
you Suzanne how can we help
good thank you guys so much for taking
my call you got it what's up um
so this is basically what I've got
husband and I we moved up we're actually
in the North Idaho area so we're just
kind of over the border from Spokane we
moved here really unexpectedly last year
after my husband lost his job and it
just ended up being such a blessing he
got a job up here and we absolutely love
it
and we don't want to leave we're closer
to family now and he got a good job here
he's been able to start a business so
he's actually working two jobs and I am
a stay-at-home mom now we've got two
baby girls
and so thank you so it's really
expensive here that's one thing we
didn't know we didn't know the area that
well but we love it so we're determined
to stay here and we were actually able
to pay off all of our debt last month
wow congratulations
yeah so in the midst of covet and babies
and this move and everything we still
manage to pay off our debt so we own our
vehicles all that and we're in a rental
but we've decided that we want to go
ahead and buy even though this Market is
really crazy and it's really expensive
here but we figured since we're
debt-free we can go ahead and pull the
trigger and do it so we're in the middle
of purchasing a place that we found
so you already have a contract out
yes we do we yeah we close here in a
couple weeks okay
yeah so
it is expensive and we know that you
know we we had started with a budget
that was a bit lower and we decided to
go higher because we just we found this
great property and it just seems like a
wonderful place to raise children and
since we're dedicated to staying in the
area we wanted to do it so you've laid
the groundwork to justify not making a
smart decision is that what happened
is am I questioning the decisions yeah
you've laid the groundwork
to have possibly made a not great
financial decision it sounds like
there's a lot of emotion behind this of
just excitement about getting in a house
and all this so give us some details
about the the financial aspect
yeah so we when we first started looking
so we've been looking for months and
months with our Realtor
and we didn't have a super firm budget
in mind but we decided around before 50
Mark was we didn't want to go much over
that we thought we could really afford
that and still be able to save money
but in this market and in this area
where we live what you can get for 450
just doesn't even seem worth it these
aren't even really starter homes they're
not even really fixer-uppers and we just
found that nothing in that price range
we were willing to go for so we decided
that we wanted to not only do a house
but get some property since we've got
little kids
so we ended up finding something but
it's about a hundred thousand more so
550. we initially started yeah so now
we're in the 550 range and how much are
you guys putting as the down payment
what percent
well we aren't because we're both
veterans so we're going through a VA
loan so we aren't actually putting
anything down
okay what's your take home
yeah so we are yeah we are going to
finance the whole thing
um which puts us at about a 2500 a month
mortgage on a 30-year
yes okay yeah Suzanne all right what's
your question you're getting us all
fired up I'm getting riled up Suzanne
yes
you're knee deep in this thing if I'm
you I'm getting out of this thing if
there's still time but you've already
signed a contract so what what's your
question
well my question is
um should we focus on saving money
because you know we're in this we're
going to be paying this mortgage should
we be saving money and focusing on that
or should we focus the extra money that
we have every month towards this
mortgage and get it down
you should have focused it before you
ever gotten this contract and had a
healthy down payment on a 15-year that's
what I would feel better about I don't
love this idea of you guys getting out
of debt and then taking on over a half
million dollars on a mortgage and
thinking that they're doing you a favor
by giving you the VA loan and is that
not a big part of your take-home pay
what is your take-home pay it is
you you have created a universe
that you want to have you want to be in
this area you want your kids in in this
area well our kids need to go ahead and
have this too so you created that as
well
and you've created a really fungible
flexible dollar amount we just got a lot
of money coming from this place in that
place in this place and here's what
you've done you've created a cloud
that allows you to a not C very clearly
and not have to see very clearly which
allows you to live in a fantasy
and now you've zeroed downed in one of
the if not the hottest real estate
markets of all time
so it takes a teeny tiny correction and
you are underwater in a half million
dollar house
working side jobs that are ah we kind of
make distance you know it and suddenly
this zero down VA loan is a nightmare
because you're underwater
and you can't get out
so tell me how much money you make
how much money comes into the Suzanne
and Company home
every month
um about
my husband's business is tough we can't
because it's a new business
but about a hundred thousand a year
right now
is that take-home pay or is that gross
yeah
that's take home
so you're taking home about eight
thousand dollars
right right and your mortgage is going
to be uh over about 31 of your take-home
pay is going towards a mortgage and
that's on a 30-year which we never ever
ever recommend we always tell people to
do the 15-year fixed rate but you're
here right but we're here Suzanne how
old are you guys
um 35 and 37. okay you've got a lot of
Life to Live and I want to see you live
it and I don't want to see you drowning
in this giant mortgage payment with
nothing down uh I've I've just talked to
too many people heard too many stories
uh and they start out like yours Starry
Eyed about the housing market and
wanting to get in and we want the
property we got to have the yard and the
budget's flexible and we're not putting
anything down
and all of a sudden they can't breathe
and we get calls I'm sure we'll take one
during this show where someone calls in
and says we're in over our head we put
nothing down on this house and we're
drowning
and so if there's time to get out I mean
it's just well you signed the contract
so you signed the contract I don't know
what the situation is there uh if you're
stuck with this thing
you may want to look at increasing
income refinancing to a 15-year and
making sure that you can afford it but
as far as paying down the mortgage I
mean it's a little late for that
conversation
because we're really we're knee-deep in
this thing uh but we recommend 10 to 20
down to avoid PMI or more on a 15 year
where the where the mortgage payment is
no more than a quarter of your take-home
pay so so far every one of the every one
of the rules has been broken which just
hurts my heart because I want to see you
guys win and you've worked so hard to
get to this point where you're debt free
and you're making these decisions and I
don't want to see you step backwards and
make a bad financial decision for your
future
when you get desperate
afraid
or angry
the higher thinking parts of your brain
shut down
and you don't make
good decisions so I have found in my
life once I get if I get greedy
if I get
uh afraid if I get desperate right after
that I get stupid
and right after I get stupid I get broke
ER
and so that's what's happening in the
housing market right now because oh God
the house prices are up and oh God the
interest rates went up and oh God I'm
never gonna be able to get a house oh
God and once your brain starts doing
that you're getting ready to do
something stupid party's over there's
going to be a lot of regret and they
call into this show and go Dave I did
something stupid Dave help me where were
you three years ago when I was doing
something stupid I'm sitting right here
that's where I've been for 30 days
and I'm still telling you the same
things
about money because these principles
that we teach are Timeless now we teach
people to get out of debt to stay out of
debt when it comes to a house it's the
only debt we don't yell at you for and
we always have told you and we still
will tell you even with the house prices
so high to get a 15-year fixed rate
where the payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay now why do
we do that just because we're killjoys
just because we don't want life to be
good for you no we do that because we
love you we care about your financial
future more than that Banker does more
than the mortgage companies do we're not
making money off of this off of the you
getting a mortgage or not getting a
mortgage are you getting a house or not
getting a house it's okay we're okay
you're okay but here's the thing
if you get in Crazy mode because of
what's going on out there you're going
to buy too much house you're gonna put
it on a 30-year and you're going to be
stuck in the middle class or lower
middle class Loop
all in the name of buying a house
because buying a house is financially
smart and I can't get one now I'll never
go well they're throwing money away Dave
they're throwing money away on rent
that's the argument calm down it sounds
like a weather forecaster when there's a
tornado warning that's the way your
brain sounds oh God you know that's the
Super Bowl that's where they get to
create all the fear oh man
so yeah that's and when your brain is
doing that
and so you know and people do it when
you know the first time I ever heard it
was like okay I live in California math
doesn't work in California well we kind
of know that but yes it does different
reasons a lot of psychedelic drugs
involved in this but yes it does work
yeah so here's the thing
speaking of California Mass
CBS News is reporting one of the biggest
hurdles in buying a home is coming up
with a hefty down payment California has
a new program too in quotes help
first time home buyers jump that hurdle
what do you think George
oh boy keep reading you got it
California's forgivable Equity Builder
loan allows first-time homebuyers who
have enough income for a monthly
mortgage payment to borrow up to 10
percent of a home's purchase price to
buy a house outright the loan has an
interest rate of zero percent but
borrowers who don't occupy the home for
at least five years may have to repay
the loan
what a concept so you can borrow your
down payment at zero percent
from California the new effort comes as
real estate prices have hit record high
in California and Rising interest rates
have pushed monthly payments up hundreds
of dollars
this is the way people's brains sound
I'm telling you I know exactly how your
brain sounds because this is how mine
sounds right before I do some stupid
butt stuff
it sounds like a beagle chasing a rabbit
oh is that what it sounds like I don't
know something like that but I mean your
brain your brain is shutting down but
the numbers down payment of 20 for a
home in California could cost upwards of
a hundred thousand dollars well no
kidding that's the thing if you get a
million dollar home and they're letting
you borrow up to ten percent at zero
percent interest so letting you borrow
100 Grand you still then have to go get
a 900 000 mortgage and that's if your
income qualifies now that's assuming you
qualifying but here's the problem okay
you can't look out there five years in
the future
and know what stupid but stuff the state
of California is going to do that makes
you want to leave
and you can't leave because then you
have to repay that loan today here is
the thing so even crazy people that
believe in debt are saying don't do it
aren't they George yeah oh yeah Credit
Karma came out and said this is probably
a bad idea if Credit Karma is saying
don't borrow the money
this tells you don't borrow the money I
mean this is like Jack Daniel's telling
you not to drink bourbon okay I mean
that's it's some Bad Bourbon right it's
got to be bad oh my God and I looked
into this your income has to be less
than 80 percent of the area median
income
and so they're saying if you're broke
enough you can then afford all of this
and like I said with the numbers housing
in California not cheap so even with the
borrowed money they're allowing people
to borrow way more to get into homes
they can't afford okay so these are less
than 80 so you're eight eight tenths of
the median the middle income of the area
tequila so this is um middle income or
lower middle income people only that are
going to get in this trap
yeah which are the people that can't get
a house oh god
listen I'm making fun of you because I
know how your brain sounds I know that
some of you have a valid concern about
buying a home in this market it's scary
out there house prices have shot up like
crazy all the indications of all the
data from the industry is it's going to
calm down no it's not going to come down
it's going to calm down and uh data that
George and I saw in a meeting yesterday
was that uh in 2020 house prices went up
32 percent uh in 21 they went up what
was it 18. uh 14 I think okay and
they're expecting them this year to go
up seven percent so the rate of in yeah
and the average house price year is
about four percent okay over the last 25
30 years so we've had this huge Spike
post pandemic the spike is tapering off
there will continue to be a an
appreciation an increase in value but it
will be a more reasonable and no you're
not going to get priced out of the
market if you continue to grow your
career you continue to manage money well
are you going to buy a house right now
probably not you might be too broke to
buy a house right now you might be too
broke to buy a car right now you might
be too broke to go on vacation right now
so don't do it
but Dave I gotta live my life yeah YOLO
baby YOLO I'm serious it all this stuff
is temporary and so calm your butt down
don't use the emotions of the current
inflationary cycle
to um cause you to dive off the deep end
into a pool with no water it's just
don't do it don't do it calm
down
Jackson is in Tampa Florida hi Jackson
how are you
hey I'm doing well how are you better
than I deserve what's up
hey got a question regarding the
mortgage I know you guys talk about
um I have no debt and uh I know you
talked about putting 15 towards
Investments and then the rest going
towards your mortgage my wife and I are
my wife and I are incredibly risk
tolerant lost about fifty thousand
dollars in our mutual funds over the
past month
um and still just sold my car invested
that money straight into the stock
market because they're on sale
um so I know well I think that the math
says Investments you're obviously a very
successful man so I'm not going to argue
with you but I'd like to genuinely know
why why do you go with that approach
versus the Investments if you're risk
tolerant
well risk tolerance has to do with what
your emotions will allow you to do
without going into freak out mode
sure okay
um and so uh someone who has a very low
risk tolerance can become a poor
investor
based on the fact that they're low risk
tolerance causes them to not take enough
risk agreed
yep someone who has two higher risk
tolerance can cause them to be a poor
investor
because they take risky Investments that
end up losing more than they make
because they live out on the edge
yeah I'm I'm like I'm 99 mutual fund I'm
one percent in football helmets so like
I'm in
I mean
for the score
stock market I like it oh this is so
care we have a new measure of things
this is awesome born on the air today I
love it
Jackson you get the award regard you
could go do whatever you want after that
so no I'm kidding all right so uh
um yeah my point is okay so I grew up in
the real estate business and one of the
things you do in the real estate
business is they take your risk meter
and they break it with a hammer real
estate people have complete risk
tolerance we're idiots we're idiots we
don't even know there's risk
okay and that's what caused me to go
broke
because I was not measuring risk so
here's the here's what ends up happening
debt
equals risk more debt equals more risk
less debt equals less risk it adds risk
to the portfolio you're saying I can
emotionally tolerate that that's one
discussion another discussion though is
what is the fastest route to wealth
regardless of risk tolerance okay what's
the fastest route to wealth and and you
know and within that then okay we've got
to discuss can I stomach that with my
risk tolerance do I have enough risk
tolerance to go that route the fastest
surest route to wealth not just uh and
most likely so
I would go back to something like the 10
167 millionaires we studied
and the number of them that said because
I had a high risk tolerance I kept a
mortgage the whole time and I invested
all the money
and uh today I have a million dollars in
mutual funds I have two million dollars
in mutual funds and I owe 600 000 on my
house the number of them that said that
was less than 10 percent
90 plus percent
said I got my house paid off and I
dumped everything in mutual funds in my
401 case Okay so the Practical facts are
the the normative way the most likely
way the highest probability way
according to the data to Bill wealth is
to invest into mutual funds and to get
the house paid off
um instead of because otherwise you
would say you would say all right I'm
going to borrow as much as I can borrow
on the house all the time and every so
often I'm going to refinance it and
throw all of that money with the cash
out into the and stay mortgaged up to my
eyeballs
yeah if the concept worked you would do
that but the problem with that is is
that it affects other things in the
Unseen and that is is that the borrower
slave to the lender you make different
decisions in your life when you don't
have a house payment
about your career yeah it puts different
stresses on your relationships
it you treat you know your children
different there's different levels of
health issues when there's no debt
versus if there's debt regardless of
risk tolerance all of those things end
up applying out there in the real world
yeah I keep going back to the car you
said you sold your car to an event do
you need a car so no no I don't that
actually that was just uh I sold I I was
able to sell my car it was a Honda a
2008 Honda Fit I sold it for 300 more
than I bought it for uh five years ago
and so I bought an electric bike and I
take that to work I'm only three miles
from work
um the problem is I do live in you know
Florida so I'm gonna start sweating here
soon
um but no the that just I just my wife
and I felt like we've got our 2015
Minivan and like we can be a one-car
family okay
um okay yeah so that that was more well
I guess I'm just I'm having a little bit
of trouble wrapping my mind around the
math of it but maybe I need to let that
I don't think here's the okay the math
here's how the math works all right in
graduate level studies in finance or
maybe even in a good school in the
senior year level
we are taught to Christina and I were
taught to
analyze two different mutual funds
okay an aggressive growth stock mutual
fund has a measure of risk called a beta
the higher the beta the higher the risk
the higher the Peaks and valleys if you
chart it the more volatile it is okay
High beta more risk okay low beta less
risk and so you take an aggressive
growth with a bay a high beta and uh
maybe a maybe a 2.5 beta or something
like that and then you take a growth in
income that might have a 0.8 beta less
than one beta a One beta is the S P 500
what the market does just to give you an
example okay so here's how the math
works if you're if you in order to
compare those two they have different
volatility so comparing Them Apples to
Apples is naive you see what I'm saying
sure so you've the way you
mathematically adjust for it is there's
an inverse formula where the beta is
flipped on its head with in an inverse
fraction so that the beta reduces the
higher beta reduces the return of the of
the risky investment and the lower beta
raises the return of the lower
investment so that after adjusted for
risk mathematically you can compare
these Apples to Apples does that make
any sense
it does I knew you were smarter than I
was and so yeah that that well I'm it's
just it's just what I was taught
academically so I'm not yeah so so the
thing is what what has never happened
though we're taught that in the
financial World Christina but we're not
taught to do that with debt
and so we compare a house with a
mortgage equally to a house without a
mortgage or an investment a property
with a mortgage equally to an investment
property without a mortgage and we do
not apply the increased risk of beta to
the math formula and so our that's what
I mean by real estate people the risk
meter is broken they don't analyze for
risk and we don't re and we don't
mathematically adjust for risk and so
when we add the beta idea or concept to
your question it says you are taking
more risks so we should put a higher
beta on your plan a lower beta on my
plan and when we risk adjust
mathematically our plans are going to be
fairly equal
um
okay
that's helpful I really appreciate it
cool I don't know if that made any sense
or not something like a barrel of Fish
Hooks but it is it is the truth that's
the Academic Way of approaching it the
spiritual way of approaching it is the
borrower is slave for the lender 100
percent of the references in the Bible
to debt say debt is stupid it's not a
sin you're a slave you're a fool you're
impulsive it always says that so if the
Bible says and I'm a Christian if the
Bible says negative things about that it
doesn't say it's a sin it doesn't say
I'm going to hell if I go to MasterCard
it's not a Salvation issue but but if if
spiritually my heavenly father is saying
in his handbook there's nothing good
about debt then I have to read that and
believe it if I'm a person of Faith
absolutely and then I can also go over
here and use my brain and use a beta and
either way I come to the same conclusion
yep that's such a great way of meshing
those two things together
yeah it's uh
but but the you know I actually
um
well speaking to a graduate level group
at uh Vandy one time and walked them
through that on the math idea and
they're like looking at me like I've
never heard that before it's because
nobody teaches it nobody talks about
debt equals risk so you need to factor a
beta into it a measure of risk
mathematically into it and when you put
in a measure of risk mathematically into
it it takes away the advantages of debt
and guess what we all know that because
when you're debt free you go off faster
so duh you know that's kind of the way
this whole thing works it's an
interesting discussion I appreciate this
question that's great Caitlyn joins us
up next she's in Arizona Caitlin welcome
to the show
hello how are you good how can we help
today
yeah I just had a quick question in
regards to overcoming a negative mindset
so I'm 29 I live out in Arizona I'm a
single mom and as you know our housing
market has been gazelle intense to say
the least
um and I'm paying about 60 of my
take-home paying rent
um like yeah I can't buy in this market
I don't make enough I pull down to about
40 last year
um and I just feel like I'm spinning my
wheels and not Treading Water feeling is
really starting to get to me so I was
hoping you could provide some insight on
that if possible yeah I mean I I'll be
honest Caitlyn I'm like I I would feel
that too if if more than half the
paycheck is going to housing that's a
that's a big chunk so tell me
um a little bit more about kind of the
situation because you are obviously in a
more expensive I don't know if it's an
area or apartment or what it is is there
other options for you to to change
locations just to at least catch your
breath and bring it down to at least you
know we recommend 25 30 but even if it
went down to 35 percent that would
change your world
right yeah I live in a two-bedroom
apartment right now and I pay about 2
000 a month I had looked at going down
to a one bedroom the only trouble with
that it was it would only Save Me Maybe
300 bucks a month but I actually work
from home
um so I need and I have my son here with
me too so I don't know how we would make
that work yeah no two bedroom yeah yeah
yeah
oh sorry I was gonna just say have you
have you driven you know 20 miles either
direction of where you currently are
just to see other prices
uh right now I'm already kind of on the
edge of
um what I would consider to be a safe
area
um so I I can look maybe a little bit
deeper into Phoenix but I just want to
make sure we're still safe and
everything's good like that so um I I
could I mean I work remotely so I could
probably Buy in other states and other
markets but my son's father's here and I
really just don't want to leave my home
state so for sure for sure
understandable and how much do you make
a year
I pulled down about 40 uh last year okay
what are you doing for work
I work at a call center for an insurance
company okay
so there's there's only two ways we can
go about this I mean we can we can spend
less and we can make more so do you have
any payments in your life that we can
get rid of do you have any debt
I don't have any debt
um I do have that going for me I don't
have any debt and I do
um anticipate my income going up
um I actually
I had a conversation yesterday with my
supervisor that made me feel like maybe
something close is on the horizon
um for getting my my pay up
um I think it's just this waiting period
between making more money and trying to
find something cheaper to rent it's just
it's mentally been draining me I think
but especially as a single mom I mean
you're you've got your how old your how
old your son
you just turned six his name's Mason I
think he might be listening that's
awesome
that's awesome oh well you're doing an
incredible job Caitlin I mean you know
the the hard thing is it's nothing that
you're doing wrong it's just that the
numbers are kind of stacked against you
and so like George said you know an
option of bringing in more I mean right
now the job market is just insane and so
I would push and look to see if you can
even I mean 40 Grand you know you're
you're doing fine but man people are
paying just insane amounts of money
right now for jobs and and since yours
is not like very specifically
specialized you know what I mean like I
feel like you could
um do all sorts of things uh even with
the experience that you've had in this
insurance role
um so you know I don't know if it's
looking for something else or a
different apartment but one of those two
things really probably it needs to shift
for your own sanity Caitlyn you know
what I mean like temporarily yeah to
have the numbers work for you
um is going to be a big deal do you have
an emergency phone Caitlyn
I do yeah okay three to six months in
there
uh I still have my baby one I have a a
one thousand dollar emergency fund and
then I have about four thousand in my my
actual uh emergency fund so I still need
to build that up okay I think building
that up may help with a little bit of
that Financial Peace and anxiety about
what if something happens if one check
doesn't come in what are we gonna do and
if you get that in place then I'm gonna
start saving up for a house slowly and I
know it's hard because there's not a lot
of margin right now but that feels like
it's the long-term goal and I'm hoping
that all this craziness is not forever
and so a year from now hopefully we're
looking at a very different picture and
you are work from home as that does open
you up but I know you've got to still
stay close to home because of the uh
situation with your son and so there's
not a ton of options here other than
let's look at the budget let's do a
budget audit where can we save every
single insurance premium every single
expense I'm going through that with a
fine-tooth comb going how can I shave
off 10 bucks 20 bucks 30 bucks yeah
absolutely and then the income I mean
the yeah income and apartment
um
situations would change too you know
yeah but you're doing a great job Kayla
you really are you're doing a great job
for for where you're at incredible no
debt you have savings I mean all of it
you really are but that 60 it oh that
that hurts me it's a tough situation and
this inflation stuff I mean it's hitting
people all over their pocketbooks from
rent to gas to food and so there's just
batting down the hatches and let's get
to work let's get the second job if we
have to Let's trim the subscriptions
that we're not using right now and all
the little luxuries that we once enjoyed
might need to go away temporarily yeah
for a season because they're saying you
know I read a report and they think in
the next 18 months with just even the
um the supply chain all of that but I'm
like I mean the hard thing is after two
years I've just learned who knows like
who knows that's right I remember April
of 2020 doing Instagram lives I did one
like every other day just to answer
questions and I remember I said hi guys
I think by August so I'll be it's all
gonna be over here we are so I'm not
predicting anything but uh I think you
just have to prepare with where we're at
the reality of what's going on and what
and what sucks is that that means
cutting back some because the numbers
everything is going up yeah and if
you're single you don't have kids
there's more options because we can go
all right let's get you a roommate now
it's more difficult when you have a
family when you've got kids involved
it's not that simple right but if you
work from home that can open you up to a
lot of options too and you may not want
to live on the outskirts of town but for
temporarily for a year if we have to
sign that lease to go all right we can
now breathe and still hit our other
financial goals I'm okay with that and
it's amazing what peace of mind even
does right like we can talk about the
numbers and the percentages and all of
that all day long but there is just
something to be said about when you do
have margin it gives you a level of
Peace like a level of like you can take
a breath
and sometimes it's worth the things you
never thought you would do I never would
live this far from wherever right people
make these claims and then when Life
Starts hitting you and you think okay is
it now I would rather live far farther
away yeah and actually have peace of
mind and margin and enjoy life a little
bit more then everything just getting
sucked out of the paycheck so much out
of our control too and so I always like
to go what is in my control yeah so in
Caitlyn's situation if I'm anyone
listening right now I'm going all right
let me make a list of ways I can make
more in ways I can spend less I'm Gonna
Make a list of five things and I'm gonna
go okay which one can I go do this week
this month and just start trying things
what can I sell on Facebook Marketplace
that's been sitting in the closet for a
while what is that second job I can take
for a few months to just supplement my
income temporarily yeah and so if you
start doing all that and that's why I
love the budget audit it's kind of a
real nerdy thing but you go man I'm way
overpaying for auto insurance let me
connect with Xander and oh my gosh I
just saved 100 bucks right there and you
start doing that in all areas we've
talked about this on your show Rachel
with cable and internet and yeah how can
we start shaving all this down our phone
bills to where now we have 200 bucks a
month yes in margin you can breathe a
little bit yeah and it's not easy I'm
not trying to make it sound like no but
it's the stuff that's the kind of the
auto the auto draft the auto pay where
you're just like oh and then you look up
two years you're like wow I've never
pushed on that or seen that you know
what I mean and doing that it does it
gives you gives you some more margin
yeah you got to advocate for yourself
and get yourself in a better financial
position and that's why our plan works
and good times and bad I mean imagine if
she had all these debt payments limiting
your life yeah great work Caitlin you've
done a great job good job
Stephanie is with us in Arlington
Virginia hi Stephanie welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello hi
um so I am a
time caller but big fan of the show I am
calling to get some advice on a
first-time homebuyer and I went in uh
the deep end for my first buy I've been
renting ever since I graduated college
and I am at 28 officiated of June and I
ended up going into a large investment
and I'm just kind of looking to get
advice in terms of liquidating my assets
and my savings hoping to do this without
any of my parents help but they are
offering and unfortunately crypto is not
an option which I had actually spent
some time learning and investing in and
thought that would maybe an option to
sell my crypto but sounds like Freddie
Mac and and such had not made
legislation that allows me to to use
that but um I I ended up selling all my
Employee Stock purchase put um my
Employee Stock which got me about half
of the down payment for my home which is
only 10 percent
um
of the actual loan and the other half
I'm looking at my 401k and the first
thing I found when I looked up in terms
of getting a 401k loan uh your show
popped up in terms of not getting ever
getting a 401k loan I am able to take
about 60k in cash or the limit of 50k
and a loan but I was curious to just get
your opinion in terms of the remaining
uh 50k that I would like to liquidate
um
what would you suggest knowing that I
have
um the 401K
and I'm happy to answer anything I got a
little bit lost in the process so you're
buying a home you want to buy a home
if you contracted for the home
contract head uh you know the home
inspection and now it's just in terms of
uh and you have you have 10 down from
the sale of Employee Stock
um yeah so in terms of the
um the mortgage so it was I'll just tell
you the numbers it was um 760 is what
would be closed on
um and you've already closed on it
oh it's not close sorry that's not the
right word contracted for so just stop
just a second I don't want to hear all
that that the bottom line is you have 10
of your down payment you've not closed
yet in the bank from the sale of
Employee Stock correct
yes or no yes or no I need no I am still
working on getting that 10 I want to get
100k
okay so how much do you have from the
sale of the employee stock
employee second
55k all right and so you could do a
Fannie Mae loan with five percent down
with that on a 15-year fixed what is
your house what is your income
incomes about 130
130. okay all right so you can probably
pull this off
um
you have no other savings at all other
than 401k and you said you owned some
crypto
yeah and I put down the 14.5 initial
with just the cash that I had and that
was it
Ernest my check
what was that well you put down 14 500
as earnest money on the contract yes yes
all right yeah so 55 and you have no
other money you have zero emergency fund
um I I do have another
um TD Ameritrade stock uh that I could
sell or get what does that work free
cash what's that worth I could I could
pull out 23. it's 55 total but it is I
could only access 23 without the double
uh it's a Roth IRA so I would get double
taxed out yeah
we don't Cash Out Roth IRAs we don't
Cash Out 401ks we're going to borrow one
401K so why is it why is it you're not
cashing out your crypto
um it sounds like in terms of sourcing
um and trusting where that cash comes
from banks are not recognizing it in
terms of a down payment
no but if you sell your crypto and you
don't have cash sell the crypto what's
it worth
um I have about 30k in crypto so so
today
um
I believe there was an issue with with
that it needs to be on the books for
about two months
uh not you know you you don't have you
have enough down payment to close on the
deal now
you just don't have enough that you want
you can you can do a 95
conventional Fannie Mae loan you have
five percent down
so you can do that but you're wanting to
put 10 down and we're trying to help you
get there plus you don't you have no
money
that you can get to except retirement
accounts and you're going to get penalty
you're gonna get your butt penalized off
okay you're too broke you're too broke
to buy this house way too broke to buy
this house but you've already contracted
for it you shouldn't have bought it
because you've got all your money stuck
okay you gotta because you don't owe me
money you have no money you're broke I
mean all your money's tied up in
retirement accounts and other things so
anyway the the deal is that um
uh uh uh
yeah I want you to have an emergency
fund in place at rainy day fund and I
don't want you I
I don't care but I'm saying what I would
advise you to do because if I were in
your shoes and woke up you need to close
on this deal you put down earnest money
you made a promise you've made a pledge
called a contractor by this house and so
yeah you need to cash out your crypto
today to be able to follow through on
this and and whatever and you need to
have twenty thousand dollars cash in the
bank after you close on this house
do not close on this house and put every
dime you have into it because as soon as
you move in crap's going to fall in
you're going to need a new roof and
you're asking for trouble you're asking
for trouble being broken by the house
and so uh it's not a blessing to buy a
house when you're broke you just got the
28 year old fever I gotta have a house
especially a three-quarter of a million
dollar house and you do make 130 Grand
which feels like a lot but you bought a
three-quarter of a million dollar house
with no money yeah so bro your 401k and
your Roth IRA does not count because you
cannot get to that without penalties and
taxes you start cashing this stuff out
you're gonna get hit with a 10 penalty
plus your tax rate so you're going to
get hit with 40 percent Dave I want to
borrow money at 40 interest to buy this
house
I would say no don't do that that
doesn't sound wise and that is exactly
what I sure wouldn't take out a mortgage
for 40 yeah right interest jeez nuts and
but I'm keeping my freaking crypto and I
know it's cool to yeah to sit at some
cool hipster bar and be like Oh I got
crypto you're broke sell it typical
crypto investor put thirty thousand
dollars cash under your pillow for
crying out loud yeah yeah you need you
need you need to put 20 000 bucks in the
bank and put the other ten thousand the
crypto with the 55 and put a 65
000 down payment on this house and close
on it yeah and for God's sakes put it on
a 15-year fixed and then get a six-month
emergency fund 20 000 and start building
up your emergency fund there so yeah
oh
I don't even
it's tough man it's
um it's just it's what we talked about
in another segment it's just you get
this picture in your head and you start
getting this fever and all of a sudden
I'm gonna do this and move that and sell
that and hold on to this and all these
competing pictures when you Collide when
you force a deal yeah you always do a
bad deal man and you're forcing this one
for sure